obviously precious does very very well
on the award circuit
would you say that things started to
come your way immediately after that or
was there any kind of
like i don't know like a residual effect
of people saying like
like oh like that was a stroke of luck
it was her first film it all came
together or
was the the train kind of like leaving
the station off and running
no i remember when i got nominated for
an oscar
like they had me at like it was the
today show or good morning america one
of the
one of them and they hadn't they like
hid me backstage to be like and when
you're nominated
like while they're reading the
nominations when you're nominated you go
out and i was like but what if i don't
guys and they're like uh then we won't
do it but you're here in case
and so but the i guess the host did not
know that i was there so i was nominated
and then they send me out but and
when i got home i still live with a
roommate at the time when i got home
my roommate had watched it and he was
like so did you hear what they were
saying right before you came out and i
was like no he was like yeah they were
like
up in gabares city bay the dark horse of
the race
and i was like oh and then i came and he
was like and then you come out
like you had not heard that and they
were already talking about how you're
definitely gonna lose
and you're a dark horse and so it's
uh yeah i've heard the idea that i'm
just lucky
um before i've heard that and
i'm an extremely unlucky person actually
i'm very very unlucky in a lot of
different ways i work really really hard
though i work really really hard
and know the uh
the hollywood seas did not part for me
in the same way that it might have for
uh maybe anna kendrick
who was nominated for the first time
that year as well uh
who then went on to star and films and
you know certain televisions and the
whole thing
the seeds did not part that same way for
me
and i assume that there are a few
factors
that uh made that so but
i am still working
10 years later i'm still working 12
years after having filmed that
i i have agency i
am comfortable with who i am i know my
voice
i know i know what i want to say to the
world i want i know what i want to give
to the world and what i want to give to
myself i know my artistry
and so you know
starring things or being in the
countries magazines or like
you know like all of these things that
say that i've made it
everything that solidifies my position
on the a-list whatever that means
doesn't actually mean anything
to my my self-worth
and my sense of artistry